but i also heard that code has hit close
to home with you
so you have loved ones working in the
hospitals right now right
yeah well it hasn't hit so far thank god
like touch wood
i'm like um i'm my sister is a midwife
um with the national health service here
and my partner's
uh sister and stepmother are both
nhs nurses as well so between
the three of us we've got three members
of family that are on like you know
right in
in front like well frontline in
community or a hospital
so i don't know how often you guys do it
but we go outside and
you know bang for clap for carers bang
our pots and pans and clap for
our national health service staff and
our carers
every thursday evening and like so we're
out there like
giving it loads and you know we just
worry about them because
but i'm so proud i'm so ridiculously
proud kelly of my sister
like and she was an elderly carer in the
community before she was a midwife she's
just one of those people that's just
like she's just really yeah she's a
nurturer and she's so good and she has
she just has that capacity enormous
mental
as well as physical capacity and i think
i know it's the same you guys your side
of the pond as
us it's like to our medical staff we are
just so
indebted yeah because you didn't it's
like so it's weird but we didn't even
think about it before you know we always
i take my kids
you know to the doctor i do all this
stuff you know you always go to the
doctor you don't think about it but god
this has really opened your eyes to how
much of a servant's heart
they all have yeah because a lot of
these
nurses have kids and families and you
know they don't want to bring it home to
and affect their family so it's it's
just a different level of sacrifice that
none of us
it's so true david my partner his sister
has got like two kids under five
and she's you know front line as a nurse
and i'm just like you know
it's like what do i do i make stories
for a living it's like it
it really does help you i mean i know
people need escapism and it's cool
beautiful distraction like that's a like
donation
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going